to find the commit which reverted to the
controls first I'll type git log now I
don't see a commit with the message
revert controls yet so I'll press the
down arrow and scroll down and here it
is since I've found it I'll press Q to
quit out of git log so this is the
commit ID of the commits that reverted
to the controls
it starts with B 0 6 7 now I want to see
how many ones were introduced in this
commit remember that the change is
introduced by this commit will be
different from the previous commit so I
can copy this commit ID type git diff
and paste it and then I'll copy and
paste this commit ID now I can just
count up the lines that have changed so
far there's two insertions and two
deletions I'll scroll down another
insertion and deletion so that's three
each another
so for each and I'll press Q to quit git
diff so the correct commit ID started
with B zero six seven and there were
four lines added and four lines deleted
by that commit